- What up VLOG?
It's me, in a meeting
that I'm about to have.
Just continuing the day,
interacting with a lot of people,
have a really interesting vibe today.
No D Rock cause a lot of
meetings that I couldn't go to,
plus kind of a saddened heart a little bit
with all the news out of Vegas.
♫ We're unstoppable.
- Yo, it's Gary V.
- If you actually don't give a fuck
the way I didn't of what
people think about you,
all through your 20's,
like you just don't care,
like you literally don't.
And, you just build
something for yourself,
you have a much better chance.
Just close your eyes until you're 29.
In Chicago.
Just got a bunch of
meetings done in Detroit.
Just enjoying the day,
enjoying it with people
I appreciate and having
fruitful meetings and debates,
just grinding through.
Flip it on D Rock.
Productive day?
- Phenomenal.
- [Gary] Ryan Harwood.
Is PureWow gonna do well?
I turned it off.
♫ Although it seems illogical,
until you follow your dreams
- What's up Instagram?
I haven't posted all day
because my heart was hurting
and my stomach was empty
and I just didn't feel it.
But, I just wanted to jump
on and very simply say,
I love you guys so much.
The engagement of everything
going with you guys
on the DM and the emails, tweets,
really lifting my spirits today.
Tough day.
Just really appreciate you, Youtube.
Thanks for watching,
thanks for commenting,
thanks for the feedback.
Tom Petty just passed away.
What a legend.
Tom Petty, you see that.
What up my man? Thank you.
Nice meeting you man.
Thanks for saying what's up.
Keep saying hi everyone.
I'm fucking flattered as fuck.
Don't ever be shy.
Or give me a head nod,
like if you see I'm busy
with the family or something.
A little head nod.
I like winking, you've seen it.
Team Human, forever.
I have so much love for the human team.
Just got love for you.
Just grinding through
and just really wanted
to take another second,
and this is going to be
just a fucking love fest,
but, it is what it is.
Make sure that you guys know
how much I have for all of you.
Literally, brushing my teeth
and wanting to make sure
that you guys know I love you.
Every day is different,
that's why you vlog.
Just wanting to send you my appreciation,
wish you the best,
and for the fun moment,
who's your favorite Knick, Ryan?
- My favorite Knick right now?
Frank.
Frenchie.
- Ryan's a big Knicks fan.
And CEO of PureWow.
He likes their point guard.
♫ I feel it's really meant to be
♫ I know I've got to chase my dreams
♫ The universe is handing me
♫ The seeds of hope of growing these
♫ Hands to the sky if you know what I know
- Watching important video on Youtube.
On Vimeo, it's so weird.
♫ You'll finally learn to stand up OK.
- If there's any thesis I
believe in more than anything
it's hacking culture.
It's understanding what
people give a shit about
and figuring out how to penetrate it
and bring value to it.
And the way I always start
is that I'm always trying
to find people that are authentic to it,
understand it, understand
the origin stories,
where it came from, have been part of it.
I did that with social media,
with Kevin Rose and others.
I've done that in wine with Bobby Catcher
and Noah Bass and others.
And, when I look at
crypto-currency and specifically,
eSports, that's what I want to do.
I've spent some time
with some great people,
but for me the Hector
meeting was super exciting
because I knew he was ingrained in it,
authentic to it, and a good dude.
Plus, had a ton of context for me,
those are the kind of
meetings I want to take
and that's what really
propelled me to take the meeting
and really the excitement
I went into that meeting.
- Gary, my man.
- Real pleasure.
- Pleasure man.
- I'm gonna drop off my bags
and be out in one second.
Honestly, of course, but
you go with who you go with.
- Yeah.
- People sitting on the
couch right now over thinking
who their perfect partner is,
like get somebody who's
right and fucking go.
- And be prepared to make
up for the shortcomings
if they're there.
- 100,000%.
- Ultimately, it's up to you, right?
- [Narrator] Wait, what?
What the hell?
Gary, what is that there for?
- Whether something fails or
not, it's ultimately up to you.
- I like people that have
been around a thing for while
and are coming at it
patient, the right way,
and we'll get to know each other better.
You travel a lot?
- I do man.
- You have a family?
- I do.
Judith, my wife, and
Olivia, seven years old.
And, then five dogs.
- Five?
Five, my favorite number.
By the way, real quick,
while I've got you, Youtube.
The reason I do this in pictures
is five's my favorite number.
- I didn't mind sacrificing,
not receiving a ton of
cash during those years
because I knew that in the end ...
- You were building something.
You were patient.
Patience.
So, when did the eye come into your world.
- About a year ago.
- About a year ago, what happened?
- I was watching Casey and Ice Vlog.
Because I started vlogging and the reason
that I started vlogging
was because, two things;
I wanted to inspire my players by acting.
I couldn't bring myself to say ...
- You've got to do this
if you aren't doing it.
- Because their excuse was
always like, I'm competing,
I am professional.
- I'm busy.
- And I was like, well,
it doesn't take that long
to connect with your fans
and maybe build a brand
that lasts.
- That's been the most fun for me.
Nobody's outworking me and I'm doing it.
Now, I've got D Rock.
You're really doing it.
I'm respect that.
But, even like today, I don't know D Rock,
have I sneezed 7,000 times already today?
I know we haven't been filming a lot,
but the way I'm feeling,
head cold right now,
99% of people are laying
in bed, out tomorrow.
- Yeah.
- You're either going to
will yourself to victory
or you're not.
- You know what is beautiful about that is
that when I used to work at AIG ...
- [Gary] You'd be home.
- I would dread getting up
at 8:30 to be at work at 9,
because I was that close.
Now, I wake up with my eyes open.
- Dude, if I felt like
the way I feel right now,
I'd be out of school the rest of the week.
Dead.
You know, because my brain
would let myself go to
that real fever place.
Right now, I'll fight it.
And, I'll do everything
like water and wash hands.
I'll do everything right, I'll fight.
And, I had to wake up
at 4:30 this morning,
are you kidding?
When you love it.
Anyway, so you're watching Casey ...
- Can I get a selfie with you?
- Yeah sure.
- Sorry man.
- It's alright man.
- [Fan] You're shooting right
now and I'm interrupting.
- No worries.
- I'm so sorry.
- That's alright.
- Let me tell you
something man, this year,
I went from, in real estate,
I went from last year
selling like 15 properties to 57 this year
and I watch you almost every day.
- Thank you brother.
- So thank you so much.
- You're welcome brother.
- Let me get a selfie with you.
- Nice to meet you, what's your name?
- Theo.
- Theo, nice to meet you
man, a real pleasure.
Like your sweater man,
and your beard.
Dude, listen, eSports is
a beast, it's a monster.
It hasn't even started.
Everybody in this place
right now, if you're like
eSports, eSports, like yeah, some people,
other people are like, what?
- Yeah.
- There's not a soul in
this hotel in a decade
that is like what.
- What is that?
- And, by the way, I lived it.
It was called social media.
- Yeah.
Isn't that the craziest thing.
- I started making videos on
Youtube in February of 2006.
- Yeah. Geez.
I think I uploaded graffiti video in 2006.
- You know what I mean?
- Bro, when you asked, I don't
want to get too detailed,
but I was taking a shower
and I was listening to you
on my JBL and I was like
who here remembers the world
before the internet?
- You're like on the shampoo.
- I lived it.
- Yeah man, that's why
we know how big it is.
- When is yours gonna ... ?
- Mine's gonna air in two days, right?
Two, three days?
- More than likely I'm gonna
steal a couple of key points.
- You take whatever you want.
- Alright, cool.
- It's all yours.
- Alright, appreciate it.
- Free of charge, so far.
You've got to work harder.
You better work smarter.
You better try things.
You better keep your
subjectiveness and your ego
at the door, because that slows you down
and it doesn't make you do.
I changed that thumbnail, I won.
Calvin I told you.